- While Heidi and I when
we had to repeat clothes
because of the auditions
- We don't like it.
- We're like
- Again!
- "We don't want to work anymore here."
(laughing)
"work in the same outfit
for two days in a row"
- I think this is the
hardest for us because
sometimes we're like five
days in the same look
and honestly, the outfit
can walk by itself.
We're always talking to one another.
We're like " Again the same outfit!"
- We hate it!
(laughing) [Kelly] That's
actually happened to me on a show.
You have to wear it for
like five days in a row and
it's like you have to
be very specific about
what you're wearing because
especially if it's stretchy at all
(scoff)
Like, elasticity wears and so
(laughing)
by day five
- It's like a complete different dress.
That happens to me all the time.
I sit down for three
days and then it's like,
"What is this?"
It's like, "Oh no, now you
have to do the red carpet."
I'm just like, "I just can't. I can't"
(laughing)
- [Kelly] And no, it's stretches as well.
Especially if it's like a jumpsuit.
I did a jumpsuit one time I was like,
"How is this elongated?"
Like it's longer and I'm so short
- [Sofia] Cut from here.
- So we just cut the bottom off...
Yeah, it's like really hard.
- All of a sudden it's a drop crotch.
- Yeah, all of a sudden.
Which is not attractive
on a person that's 5'3".
- [Simon] Uniforms.
(laughing)
- [Group] No.
- We don't want uniforms.
Look what he's saying that
we should wear uniforms.
- [Heidi] No!
- [Simon] Yes. It's easy.
- [Terry] AGT uniform.
- [Heidi] no, no no.
- [Sofia] I quit.
- I am actually gonna
side with Simon on this
because it'd be way easier.
- You might like them.
- A nice AGT uniform.
You wear A, I wear G, you wear T.
- [Simon] Yes.
- [Sofia] No.
(laughing)
How about this week we can
swap our uniforms at least.
- [Heidi] Yeah.
(laughing)
- Let us do it for one day please.
- No.
- [Kelly] No
- Look at her face she just said "nope".
- Only if you let me
dress you for one day.
- [Simon] Okay. Done.
(gasping)
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
(Audience applause)
(Heidi screeching and clapping)
- [Group] (laughing)
- I've been waiting for this for years.
- You have to keep this promise.
- Why are you agreeing without my concent?
(laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
- We'll do it together.
We'll go shopping together.
We hook him up with a new outfit.
- Oh okay. Him! Okay good. Good.
- Yeah you get to dress him and
he gets to dress y'all.
- [Terry] I thought ti was
something like a uniform.
- [Heidi] This one right here!
- What are you going to wear?
You have to do something.
This is not just a bet that
you get Scott-free off.
- I'm going shirtless.
- Shirtless
- [Kelly] Okay!
- I'm going shirtless.
- [Kelly] That's where we
all win. Everyone wins.
- [Terry] Everything
matches with shirtless.
- Everyone, everything wins.